How did you get punched?
Who,
why did that Lady Punch you?
It was a 20 year old,
uh,
bipolar girl.
Uh,
I was at levity live.
I did a show,
came offstage when,
into the green room for a few minutes and then came back out and I was standing
to the left of the stage and I don't always shake hands and do all that shit
after the show.
I just don't feel it's in the job description.
Sometimes I'll do it,
sometimes they won't.
But some people started coming up to me and shaking hands and taking pictures
and this guy approaches me,
so look like you a little bit.
Uh,
stands to my right and he goes,
can I get a picture that go?
Sure.
I stand in my right.
I'm looking at him talking to him.
He's like,
yeah,
I enjoyed the show,
but my daughter wanted a punch you in the face.
He didn't even finish the word face.
And I get suckered from this.
I didn't even know she was in the fucking room all sudden Bam.
Whoa.
And I mean Bam.
I mean fucking,
you know,
I was,
I don't know if you ever get fucking suckered.
Uh,
I could feel the,
I close and immediately,
you know,
and I looked right at him.
This is how good my instincts were.
Even when I was in shock,
I go,
did you just fucking set me up?
No.
It's nothing like that,
man.
He didn't jump in and he didn't jump in and go to his daughter.
What are you doing?
And I was kinder.
I to this day,
believe it was complicit.
Uh,
he was complicit in it,
but still pursuing it.
What did she don't?
I finally looked at her.
I go,
why,
why you fucking it,
why'd you do that?
Because you're mean.
She thought I was racist and sexist.
Meanwhile,
there was a table of black people,
Dominican.
It was a very diverse crowd.
Absolutely loved it.
Coming into my defense after that happened,
nobody got offended.
Even a friend of mine who see me my in time,
cause you won't even be in that political that night that she had Birkenstocks
on and you know,
bipolar and,
and,
and uh,
I'm still pursuing it.
And the guy didn't apologize,
nothing he was,
he didn't appall it,
but he,
I said,
you just fucking said no,
I didn't man.
And it's,
it's nothing like that.
You know,
I,
she said I shouldn't have brought here,
brought her here.
But you did,
you'll weaponize your bipolar Datta is what you did.
I believe they sat down at the table before they left the house.
He knows what I did for comedy and he be,
he hated.
He didn't have the balls to do it himself.
You thing.
Yeah.
That's what I think.
Look at you.
I'm going to work,
but those kettle bells before I leave here,
I'm going to find this mother fucker.
But it gets you on a bike and gets you to burn off some energy.
Jesus across my penis,
my rifle coffees and love dish,
extra owned coffee.
It's very potent.
I want to contribute anything veterans do.
I got some bags for,
I'll get you some.
That's great stuff.
But yeah,
so the fucking hike you had the funniest.
This is what's funny about it.
For years.
People tell me to,
you know,
keep your temper in check at Bubba Ba.
You know,
you'll fuck up the curator.
You don't Bubba,
I've been hearing that for years after this happened.
They're all gone.
Why didn't you hit her back?
Why do you I you,
you texted me like the next day or that night.
I can't remember.
And you said you go,
it's made me laugh of five minutes.
You go,
Joe Goes,
I thought y'all was gonna a quick thing.
You didn't hit her but she'll,
cause I would have fucking leg whipped her,
which made me laugh so hard because she's his frail thing and if you leg whip
to,
you would have taken her legs Claire off like a helicopter blade.
I was belly laughing for five.
You will leg whip weapon,
this leg kicker.
I don't think I would have said,
okay well look scares me.
Well you got to kill it.
Someone Punch you.
The real problem is like someone,
even a garage.
I saw you on the part where you hurt your eye clip you in the pot.
I have a permanent dent in my face.
You can see it.
I have a permanent dent.
I don't,
she had a ring on.
Really?
There's a little dent there.
Yeah,
we had a ring on.
Someone could hit you.
The number one down.
Joe's good for you.
That would've been embarrassing.
You could lose your vision.
I mean that's 100% possible happens to people.
I had a slight concussion.
She really fucking caught me flooding.
I'm not shocked.
Especially if you didn't know you.
What would you have done?
I don't know.
I hope I wouldn't have done what I think I do.
You know,
cause you could lose a lot.
I know you get insurance for that.
And the Mike,
the real problem is when you're not thinking,
when you get hit and then you immediately respond,
that's a real problem because look,
you've seen that video of that giant six foot five guy who punched that 11 year
old girl in the face.
She had a comment.
She,
well she definitely,
shit kid walked up to when it was with her and she definitely shouldn't have
pushed him first,
but he definitely shouldn't have punched her in the face is big giant fucking
guy.
I know with a nice shot.
You don't want,
you don't want to punch a girl.
You don't want to hit a girl.
And I didn't don't,
you don't want to go into that reptilian part of your brain either.
That just responds to being assaulted.
Oh,
that was killed.
That's why they're dangerous.
I saw you that,
remember that clip years ago you were in the parking lot and the comedy store
arguing with some broad,
oh,
that feminist lady and I bust mean I thought you were going to,
they're all,
I was trying to be nice to the meanest people on there.
I was nice to that lady for a long time until she coming to town.
What?
She's gonna she's gonna get hit me with her cigarette.
I'm like,
listen,
you're not doing anything.
I know.
I was watching it go.
What's going to happen next?
But it's just so stupid that people think they can get away with things like
that.
Worldly.
If you were alone in a parking lot with that girl and she punched him in the
face like that.
What if I even fucking cracker there?
I said this and I've been making this point.
You want true gender equality?
If we had it,
I could have fucking knocked her the fuck out and everybody went,
you know what?
She had it coming.
Yeah,
we all went home.
Well,
they would have been liberated.
You showed amazing restraint and not hitting her back cause I wasn't drinking
and what what if you were drinking,
I would've probably wrestled her.
At least cuffed her
fair slap.
Yeah.
I would have gave her from behind though.
It dirty one.
Oh,
dirty.
Yeah,
I would have came from here.
Do you ever see that?
You'll be sad video.
This is a kid,
a black kid walking down the straight and some black neighbor and he's rapping
Assam Shit and this black kid walks up from behind like in a wife beater and
winds up from his ass hole with an open hand.
It would blow your hands out if you had the headphones.
Yeah.
But I,
uh,
I was proud of myself and that's why I was laughing after the incident.
People I know who've been telling me,
you know,
cool.
It a Weber you,
they were all like,
yeah,
shut off.
Fuck and body slam
my entre.
Like you shut up.
I was so proud of myself for once that I was the adult in the room and I,
I,
you know,
I know in the times will limiting in wouldn't matter the circumstance if the
toxic masculinity,
if,
if I croaked her.
Well,
I don't know man.
If somebody punches you and you punch them back,
I don't know what the fucking rules are.
Oh,
I do.
I mean,
she's obviously very small.
That would've been a real problem because she's small,
but you shouldn't be fucking hitting people.
Now what you said you were working on it like,
no,
you're still in the middle of it.
Like what's going on with it?
Uh,
yes.
I,
uh,
pursuing it and they,
it's just so you can tell they don't give a fuck.
The Da was a woman in that county.
And now she's off the case.
For some reason they shuffled the,
um,
but they went,
they,
you know,
it should be a salt.
I aggravator so,
but of course you can't go cause if you don't get that,
I can't sue her civilly.
If I lost that,
it would hurt my case.
At least that's the logic they would tell on me.
So they're trying to get her with like second degree harassment and now there
there's a new woman on the case and she said they,
they're making her go to anger management and uh,
cause she has mental issues and uh,
I'm not looking for money.
I just want to make an example of her.
So,
but why not pursue it as a salt?
What's clearly assault?
I know.
Well you tell me.
So as your lawyers decision to not pursue it,
no.
Nobody.
First of all,
nobody wanted to take the case because I'm fine.
Really?
Yeah.
They're like,
wow,
you site's not fucked up.
You're not in a wheelchair.
You're not.
But yeah.
Did I give the lowest credit for that much?
They're honest.
It's all about the money,
but that's crazy.
But I found the guy,
this Guy Andrew [inaudible],
who was a lawyer who was a marine,
and I said to he,
he contacted me and he put me in touch first with a Russian woman who,
who took about three of my calls and she get tired because it was no money
involved.
And he hooked me up on another guy,
uh,
another lawyer who right now I'm dealing with.
But um,
yeah,
they will all right up front that the,
if there's no money involved and you're not permanently,
you're not going to,
you know,
but I just want,
I don't want money and this guy sort of agree with it's Andrew [inaudible].
He's a marine.
He just wants to make an example.
She said I was racist and sexist,
you know.
Uh,
so I just want to make an exact,
I'm not looking for money,
but it's her father that really pisses me off.
She's nuts.
How old is just broads nuts?
Like 2021 goes to a school in upstate New York.
So she's not that,
not she lives on her own,
but it's the fucking old man that was complicit in it.
I think he actually used her as like a weapon that night.
It seems like it'd be way harder to prove that she was,
that he was complicit in it would be to,
I agree with that.
She punched,
you know,
I agree.
Did she apologize ever?
Never.
She,
she,
she ran up into the lobby,
which is where you normally,
where you take pictures with fans and she didn't,
she,
she put her head on a table and was crying after she realized what she done or
whatever,
you know,
they took it or like a psychiatric hospital.
So they're saying,
well,
you know,
I,
I just want to make an example of her.
That's all I,
I don't,
I'm not looking for,
but,
but uh,
you know,
that's ridiculous.
And the next time I will hit back,
you think,
yeah,
don't,
no,
wait a minute.
Show you confusing me.
Now it's too little.
Or give me a kick that would just like hurt her ovaries.
What?
All three of them for a knee go from the lead of the pussy would be how you
damage.
I don't want to lose my knee.
I just would say don't hit her,
but then you get them head around.
Even in the future,
if somebody does know I'm not,
I would,
I wouldn't never,
well,
you've been proved dabbing or prove it because you haven't done it.
You didn't do it.
You had the ultimate opportunity.
Somebody actually hit you.
You didn't hit him,
but it's one of my proudest moments.
Yeah,
it should.
Should be proud of that.
I've been an amazing,
we're into it with a fan of is somebody in the audience know?
I've been in twice.